Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战赛。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever wondered what a psychological wellbeing practitioner actually does? Perhaps
这些原则都同样适用。还有丰厚的奖品等着你，由Lisa亲自颁发。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你有没有想过心理健康从业者（PWP）到底是做什么的？也许
you're curious about how to train as one and whether it's a paid role. Perhaps you're wondering about the career progression for PWPs. Well, today I am sitting down with Ben, a qualified PWP, as we discuss the ins and outs of this really important mental health profession. From training paths to daily responsibilities, we are breaking down everything you need to know about becoming a PWP. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which is now an award-winning podcast. We won the Best Science and Technology category at the Independent Podcast Awards 2024. It means a great deal to me. And thank you so much to you, my listeners and my watchers, because this, you know, I adore this podcast and knowing that you guys love it too,
你很好奇如何接受相关培训，以及这是否是一份带薪工作。也许你正在考虑PWP的职业发展前景。今天，我邀请到了合格的PWP——Ben，我们将深入探讨这个非常重要的心理健康职业。从培训路径到日常职责，我们将剖析你成为PWP所需了解的一切。你好，欢迎收听《Aspiring Psychologist》播客，这现在是一个获奖播客了。我们在2024年独立播客奖中获得了最佳科学技术类奖项。这对我很重要。非常感谢你们，我的听众和观众，因为我知道，我热爱这个播客，而你们也喜欢它，
and that you find it to be a really helpful support in your career or in learning about mental health it means a great deal. So that's going to live on the desk behind me when I'm recording podcast episodes. So there will be two ways of telling the age of this podcast. One whether or not I have my mole, what stages of mole removal I'm at, and whether I've got my award-winning trophy in the background. Anyway, today's episode, as we said, in the hook, is all about the very important role of psychological well-being practitioner. If you find it helpful, please do like, share, comment, subscribe, tell your friends about it. If you're listening on spotify please do rate if you're listening on apple podcast please do rate and review and please wherever you are listening or watching
并且觉得它在你的职业生涯或学习心理健康知识方面提供了非常有益的支持，这对我意义重大。所以，当我录制播客时，这个奖杯会一直放在我身后的桌子上。以后可以通过两件事来判断这档播客的“年龄”：一是看我有没有那颗痣，以及痣切除到了什么阶段；二是看我背景里有没有那个获奖奖杯。总之，正如我们在开场白中所说，今天的话题是关于心理健康从业者（PWP）这一重要角色。如果你觉得有帮助，请点赞、分享、评论、订阅，并告诉你的朋友。如果你在Spotify上收听，请评分；如果你在Apple Podcast上收听，请评分并留下评论。无论你在哪里收听或观看，
please subscribe or follow the show it really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcast that you like let's dive in and chat with ben and i will be along on the other side of this podcast and i hope you find it really useful I just want to welcome along our guest today, Ben Olofsson. Hi, Ben. Welcome along to the podcast. Hi, Marianne. Thank you. Thanks for having me. Pleasure to be here. Oh, thanks for reaching out. I think you originally reached out to praise my work, you know, which always goes down well.
请订阅或关注本节目，这对你喜欢的任何播客来说都是最暖心的支持。让我们开始与Ben的对话吧，节目结束后我会再回来，希望你觉得这期内容很有用。我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Ben Olofsson。你好，Ben。欢迎来到播客。你好，Marianne。谢谢你。谢谢邀请我。很高兴能来到这里。哦，谢谢你的联系。我想你最初联系我是为了称赞我的工作，你知道，这总是让人很开心。
And then we got chatting and we realised that it had been my intention to cover what a PWP is, but I've never actually done it. So I'm delighted that we met at the time that we did. And hopefully we can help our audience to be illuminated on what a PWP is and whether they would want to be one. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I think, you know, there's a lot of talk about other roles you know a lot of what i've come across has been about assistant psychologist which obviously is a fantastic role and a very common route into psychology training but yeah i don't think a lot has been said or as much as we said about the pbp route so, happy to have that conversation and share my experiences today.
然后我们聊了起来，意识到我一直打算介绍什么是PWP，但从未真正做过。所以我很高兴我们在那个时间点相遇。希望我们能帮助我们的听众了解什么是PWP，以及他们是否想成为一名PWP。是的，绝对是。我想，关于其他角色的讨论很多，我遇到的大多是关于助理心理学家的，这显然是一个很棒的角色，也是进入心理学培训的一条非常常见的途径，但我觉得关于PWP途径的讨论还不够多。所以，很高兴今天能进行这次对话并分享我的经验。
Perfect. So as you so rightly said, there's no right or wrong way to become a qualified HCPC psychologist. But a common way is to think about doing an assistant psychologist route or maybe even to work in education. But obviously, over the more recent time period, other routes have become available, which do actually involve professional qualifications. Can you tell us what drew you to the PWP roles? the fact that you start with the training gear where you complete a university qualification with a lot of support, guidance, use that training gear to really develop those key therapeutic skills that are so, so important for our clinical practice. With a lot of assistant psychologists I was looking at, I applied for a a couple fortunately didn't get onto those but then I looked into other routes and some across the PDP routes and yeah I was really attracted
太棒了。正如你所说，成为一名合格的HCPC心理学家没有对错之分。但一种常见的方式是考虑走助理心理学家的路线，或者去教育领域工作。但显然，在最近一段时间里，其他途径也出现了，这些途径确实涉及专业资格。你能告诉我们是什么吸引你选择了PWP角色吗？是因为你从培训年开始，就能在大量支持和指导下完成大学资格认证，并利用那一年真正发展那些对临床实践至关重要的核心治疗技能。我当时申请了几个助理心理学家的职位，可惜没成功，后来我研究了其他途径，发现了PWP路线，是的，我真的被
to that training experience that you get and then yeah after that once you complete that a qualified role and yeah I'll see you know the training in low intensity cognitive baby therapy CBT so yeah that was really what what drew me to that. Perfect so it's a year of training and in that year you're seeing clients as well you're kind of learning on the job? Yeah so there is a little bit of learning on the job so in terms of how it's structured so you start with you know a few months of university training where you're not seeing any clients so that first period this three month period is you do a university module in assessments and engagement so looking at how you do an assessment so you might be doing a lot
那种培训体验所吸引。在那之后，一旦完成培训，就是一个合格的角色。而且培训内容是低强度认知行为疗法（CBT），所以这就是吸引我的地方。太棒了，所以这是一年的培训，在这一年里你也要见客户，是在工作中学习吗？是的，确实有一点边工作边学习。关于结构，你先进行几个月的大学培训，期间不接触任何客户。这最初的三个月，你要完成一个关于评估和参与的大学模块，学习如何进行评估。你可能会进行大量的
of shadowing of qualified pvps or whether that's you know other other professions in the therapy service so so yeah so you're working toward your assignments okay uh so like the osci is is a big thing at the beginning of the training so you know that's uh where you're being observed to see whether you're okay to being given the green light to do assessments you know in the real world with with real clients and yeah so yeah there's a lot of learning on the job and then the next module is all about interventions okay so you know learning low intensity cbt interventions like you know behavioral activation cognitive restructuring these sorts of things and yeah that's a little bit less practice you get for that so you might do a week or so of teaching and then you're more or less thrown straight into
对合格PWP的跟岗观察，或者观察治疗服务中的其他专业人员。所以，你是在为作业做准备。好的，比如OSCE（客观结构化临床考试）是培训初期的重头戏，那是你被观察以确定你是否具备在现实世界中与真实客户进行评估的资格。所以，确实有很多边工作边学习的内容。接下来的模块是关于干预措施的，学习低强度CBT干预，比如行为激活、认知重组等。那部分的实践练习会少一些，你可能接受一周左右的教学，然后就差不多直接被投入到
the deep end so to speak so yeah there is a lot of learning on the job but I think that's quite you know exciting and you know it's nothing to be scared of really having gone through it because all of the clients you'd be working with have been very carefully you know screened and deemed suitable to be for a trainee pwp to be working with so yeah it's a really i think it's a really really good experience yeah that's so reassuring and i think when we're a trainee in anything there's that kind of imposter syndrome thinking oh i'm gonna make this client worse you know someone else would be way better to see them than me but it's actually trying to hold on to that which is a really important point that they've been deemed as being appropriate to be seen by somebody at
所谓的“深水区”了。所以，确实有很多边工作边学习的情况，但我认为这很令人兴奋，没什么好怕的。因为你接触的所有客户都经过了非常仔细的筛选，被认为适合由实习PWP进行接待。所以，我认为这是一次非常非常好的经历。太令人安心了。我想当我们作为任何职位的实习生时，都会有那种冒名顶替综合症，觉得“我会让这个客户的情况变糟，别人肯定比我做得更好”。但实际上，要记住他们已经被评估为适合由你这个培训水平的人来接待，这一点非常重要。
your level of training and I think that's really important. Yeah absolutely I think imposter syndrome is something I've learnt even being a qualified PDOP and potentially looking to you know explore a clinical clinical psychology training at some point in the future. And speaking of lots of other people who are current trainees in clinical psychology, that may never leave you, unfortunately, that imposter syndrome. But yeah, you're right. You get lots of support through the training period. Certainly my experience is fantastic. From the service, you've got your one-toto-one supervisor you've got in-service buddies they set you up with you've got your academic tutor there's lots and lots of support so any time you know if you're going through personal difficulties
是的，绝对。我认为冒名顶替综合症是我即使在成为合格PWP后，甚至在考虑未来探索临床心理学培训时，也一直在学习应对的东西。说到很多目前正在接受临床心理学培训的人，不幸的是，这种感觉可能永远不会消失。但你是对的，在培训期间你会得到很多支持。我的经历确实非常棒。在服务机构里，你有一对一的督导，有为你安排的同伴，有学术导师，支持非常多。所以任何时候，如果你经历个人困难，
perhaps or just struggling with the nature of the course because it yeah to be fair you know it's really really rewarding and I think overall positive experience but it can be there are periods where it is it can be challenging you know it's quite um you know to balance that academic those academic roles you know doing assignments preparing for exams OSCEs whatnot and alongside clinical work it can be demanding so it's important to reach out you know recognize you know if you are experiencing any sort of signs of burnout or just generally struggling to reach out for that support. Absolutely. And we might just think, oh, it's only a year of my life. I can get that done. But it is a calendar year. And,
或者只是在课程性质上感到挣扎——因为说实话，这确实非常有回报，总体上是积极的经历，但有时也会充满挑战。平衡学术角色（做作业、准备考试、OSCE等）和临床工作确实要求很高。所以，如果你感到任何倦怠迹象或感到挣扎，一定要寻求支持。绝对的。我们可能会想，“这只是我生命中的一年，我能熬过去”。但这是一个完整的日历年。而且，
you know, you do matter. And, you know, sometimes there can be a tendency to think, oh, I can commute for two and a half hours a day for a year. That's fine. But actually that's not practical in the grand scheme of things and you've got to fit your own life around it. So, yeah, I think being considerate about where you apply and where you're going to work and how well that's going to fit in your life and whether you might be really lonely as well if you do up sticks and move. So you've almost come up with a plan to help yourself to thrive rather than just thinking. So even when I started
你很重要。有时人们倾向于认为，“我可以一年里每天通勤两个半小时，没问题”。但实际上，从大局来看这并不现实，你必须围绕它来安排自己的生活。所以，我认为在申请地点、工作地点以及它如何融入你的生活方面要多加考虑，如果你搬到异地，是否会感到非常孤独。所以你几乎是制定了一个计划来帮助自己茁壮成长，而不是仅仅去想。甚至当我开始
my doctorate in clinical psychology, I was lucky that I did make friends, but I'd imagined I would be coming along and it would be a bit like undergrad, you know, that we all started, there was 15 of us in those days. We all started, we'd all be single, we'd all be exact same stage of life, we'd be the best of buddies and we'd be able to go out at weekends and in the evenings and, you know, help me to settle into this local area. But actually people were spread across a patch, you know, probably an hour's drive from the university. Some of them were married, some of them were married some of them were in long-term relationships only I think two of us were single when we first joined the course and different age spreads as well and so you can't always rely upon your cohort being the
我的临床心理学博士学位时，我很幸运交到了朋友，但我曾想象这会像本科一样，我们一起开始，当时我们有15个人。我们都单身，处于完全相同的人生阶段，我们会成为最好的伙伴，周末和晚上可以一起出去玩，帮助我适应当地。但实际上，大家分散在各处，离大学可能有一小时车程。有些人结婚了，有些人处于长期关系中，我们刚入学时只有两个人是单身，年龄跨度也很大。所以你不能总是指望你的同届同学会成为
ones who are going to become your friends and support systems I think we do need to go into this with thinking what's going to best set me up to thrive yeah absolutely I mean you highlight a really good point there that you know wherever you go you just don't know who you're going to be training with and I think at the same time that diversity of experiences you know people come from different you know backgrounds different ages I think it's a really nice thing. For example, me, I was the only male out of seven of us, I think, in our service when we trained. And a lot of people were slightly older. But that's quite nice, I think, about the trainee PwP position and the once qualified as well. You get a lot of mixture of people with different backgrounds different work experiences um so you can learn a lot from you know different people just pick
你的朋友和支持系统。我认为我们需要带着“什么最能让我茁壮成长”的想法进入这个阶段。是的，绝对。你强调了一个很好的观点，无论你去哪里，你都不知道会和谁一起受训。同时，这种经验的多样性——人们来自不同的背景、不同的年龄——我认为这是一件非常好的事情。例如，我当时是我们服务机构七个人中唯一的男性。很多人年纪稍大一些。但我认为PWP实习生职位以及合格后的职位，其美妙之处在于你会遇到背景和工作经验各异的人，
little bits up especially if you're working in an office environment you know you can just pick little bits up and it can be really helpful to help you know you to improve your own practice really so yeah I think it's really there's lots of things to consider but I think that is a nice aspect of at least my experience of the course absolutely there is so much to draw upon from your cohort that some people might have had experience in one client area and you know you can kind of look to them as the expert and others you know you might feel like I've never worked with this particular clinical presentation or population before. And you can kind of come together and support one another.
所以你可以从不同的人身上学到很多东西，特别是在办公室环境中，你可以学到点滴经验，这真的有助于提高你自己的实践水平。所以，有很多事情需要考虑，但我认为这是我课程经历中美好的一面。绝对的，你可以从你的同届同学身上汲取很多东西，有些人可能在某个客户领域有经验，你可以把他们视为专家；而对于其他人，你可能会觉得“我以前从未与这种临床表现或人群合作过”。你们可以聚在一起互相支持。
So is it like the CAP roles where individual trusts are recognising they would like to have this many qualified PWPs? So they kind of almost fund a set amount of training roles to then work in a particular service? Yeah, I believe so. I think it is similar to that role as much as I'm aware of. So yeah, all these courses are NHS funded. And yeah, in most cases, I mean, I can only speak of my experience, but that, yeah, so seven of us uh were there and i think everyone who trained and wished to stay on and and uh you know substantive role qualified pvp there was an interview process still which was you know but but yeah no it's um that was fine i got through that and uh yeah ended up with the qualified position in the same uh trust Different service though. So I started working just what we call in the core service,
那么，这是否像CAP（儿童心理健康从业者）角色一样，各个信托机构意识到他们需要一定数量的合格PWP？所以他们几乎是资助了一定数量的培训岗位，然后让他们在特定的服务机构工作？是的，我相信是这样。据我所知，它与那个角色很相似。所有的课程都是NHS资助的。在大多数情况下——我只能说我的经历——我们七个人都在那里，我想每个受训并希望留下来担任合格PWP实质性职位的人，虽然仍有面试过程，但最终都成功了，并在同一个信托机构获得了合格职位。不过是不同的服务部门。我最初在所谓的“核心服务”工作，
but then since qualified, moved into the long-term conditions service. So working more sort of with health psychology, if you like, working with people with diabetes or IBS or chronic pain or fatigue conditions, et cetera. So that's been a really interesting transition and a really new and exciting challenge to develop different skills once qualified so yeah absolutely so i think i'm right in saying actually cap roles they are you train and then work as a qualified worker
但合格后，转到了“长期病症服务”部门。所以更多地涉及健康心理学，比如与糖尿病、肠易激综合征（IBS）、慢性疼痛或疲劳症患者合作。所以这是一个非常有趣的转变，也是一个在合格后发展不同技能的全新且令人兴奋的挑战。所以，是的，绝对。我想我没说错，CAP角色是你受训后在同一个服务机构担任合格工作者，
in the same service it's almost a little bit like a preceptorship role but yeah if someone's listened to that episode more recently than i've done it please do correct me if i'm wrong but this actually is just we kind of are going to train this many pwps and we hope there'll be a job for a qualified pwp once you qualify but it's not a guarantee yeah not necessarily but uh yeah my experience it was still the same so it's just the different departments for the long-term conditions department uh bs you're right yeah okay and i think i'm right in saying that if you are doing your pwp route in england that you attract what's called health education england funding hee which then means that for a fixed period of time after you graduate,
这几乎有点像入职培训角色。如果有人最近听过那期节目，请纠正我。但对于PWP，我们只是计划培训这么多PWP，并希望合格后会有工作岗位，但这并不是保证。是的，不一定。但我的经历是一样的，只是部门不同，长期病症部门。你是对的。好的，我想我没说错，如果你在英国走PWP路线，你会获得所谓的“英格兰健康教育”（HEE）资助，这意味着在你毕业或获得资格后的一段时间内，
I think it is, or after you qualify, you then can't apply for any additional HEE funding, which would mean that you have to kind of plan this into your career route if you are wanting to then go on to the doctorate in clinical psychology, for example. Could you tell us a little bit more about that, Ben? Yeah, absolutely. So that is something certainly to consider if you wish to, you know, especially I think if you're wanting to think about the doctors of clinical psychology and clinical psychology training. Yes, you have to. So it's once you qualify, it's the date in which the exam boards have, you know, you've received that qualification from those exam boards, that's all been okayed. And then it's a two year period until then you're
你不能申请任何额外的HEE资助。这意味着如果你想继续攻读临床心理学博士学位，你必须把这一点规划到你的职业路线中。你能多告诉我们一些吗，Ben？是的，绝对。如果你想考虑临床心理学博士学位和临床心理学培训，这确实是需要考虑的。是的，你必须这样做。从你获得资格的那一天起，也就是考试委员会确认你获得该资格的那一天起，会有两年的期限，在此期间你
able to start and receive, you know, embark on any future funded training. So for me, yeah, it's 2023, which I qualified. And so yeah, until 2025, I can't do any further training. Perfect. Thank you. And I think, again, I'm right in saying that you could apply for it, but you couldn't start and receive and start that training until those two years had passed. So because the application process is quite long, for example, for Declincy, the deadlines are in November, but it doesn't start until the following September so if you knew that your two years was going to tick over before the courses start in September
不能开始或接受任何未来的资助培训。对我来说，我是2023年获得资格的，所以直到2025年，我不能进行任何进一步的培训。太棒了，谢谢。我想我没说错，你可以申请，但在那两年过去之前，你不能开始并接受该培训。因为申请过程很长，例如临床心理学博士，截止日期在11月，但直到次年9月才开始。所以如果你知道你的两年期限会在9月课程开始前结束，
then you should be you should be fine for that yeah I think there's a bit of confusion online a bit of confusion but yeah that is I did look into it and yeah that is definitely right so people may have thought it's where you when you can apply for it but it's not so you can apply and then it's when you start the next training. Great thank you so what sort of clinical presentations might a trainee or and or qualified PWP be working with? Yeah so you know predominantly it's mood, depression and anxiety or generalised anxiety. So those are the main mental health presentations that you'd be working with. Could also be people with panic disorder, could be people with difficulties with sleep. I know
那么你应该就没问题了。是的，网上确实有点困惑，但我研究过，这绝对是正确的。人们可能认为是指申请时间，但不是，是指你开始下一次培训的时间。太棒了，谢谢。那么，实习或合格的PWP通常会处理哪些临床表现？是的，主要是情绪、抑郁和广泛性焦虑。这些是你主要处理的心理健康问题。也可能是惊恐障碍患者，或者有睡眠困难的人。我知道
not in my service that I work for, but in services maybe at step two they as a pwp they may work with people with with OCD but I don't I don't know that's not every service that differs from service to service but yeah it's predominantly low moods and anxiety but for me working in the long-term conditions service now a lot of what we do is about you know acceptance work or adjustment like adjusting to you know living with a long-term condition so you may do one-to-one work in the form of guide self-help which is typically around about six or so sessions you know varies in like maybe 30 minutes to 45 minutes perhaps where you're working through you know supporting people with low mood
在我工作的服务机构里没有，但在某些服务机构的第二阶段，PWP可能会处理强迫症（OCD），但我不知道，这因服务机构而异。但主要是低落情绪和焦虑。但对我来说，在长期病症服务部门工作，我们做的很多工作是关于接纳或调整，即适应与长期病症共存。你可能会进行一对一的工作，形式是引导式自助，通常大约六次左右，每次30到45分钟，支持那些有低落情绪
and generalised anxiety or you may be doing group work as well so for me in my in my service we run a workshop called building emotional resilience living with a long-term condition yeah and that can be really lovely people can connect and share their thoughts and you know work together almost and learn from each other as service users to support each other with long-term living with long-term conditions which obviously can pose its own challenges and also you may also do online work as well so see cbt computerized uh or low intensity cbt which yeah so you know doing the same sort of things you'd be doing with guided self-help maybe over the phone or face to
和广泛性焦虑的人。或者你也可以进行小组工作。在我的服务机构，我们举办一个名为“建立情绪韧性，与长期病症共存”的研讨会。这真的很棒，人们可以建立联系，分享想法，几乎是共同努力，作为服务使用者互相学习，支持彼此与长期病症共存，这显然会带来挑战。你可能还会进行在线工作，即计算机化CBT或低强度CBT。所以，做你在引导式自助中做的同样的事情，可能通过电话或面对面，
face but just sit that online so guiding you know clients through online computer modules to support them managing low mood and anxiety maybe sleep difficulties as well so yeah it's quite a varied mixture of things which i really like that variety of you know one-to-one work working in groups working different you know methods of delivery as well so doing there's a lot of telephone work but you can you know do video face to face so yeah that's really nice it's quite a varied role i think which is really good to develop a lot of those skills therapeutic skills yeah absolutely am i right in thinking you're supervised by a qualified senior pwp or might you be supervised by a a clinsych or another HCP psychologist? Talk to us about the supervision then. Yeah, I think most people, at least in my
只是在线进行。引导客户通过在线计算机模块，支持他们管理低落情绪和焦虑，可能还有睡眠困难。所以，这确实是一个非常多样化的组合，我真的很喜欢这种多样性：一对一工作、小组工作、不同的交付方式。有很多电话工作，但你也可以进行视频或面对面交流。这真的很棒，我认为这是一个非常多样化的角色，对于发展那些治疗技能非常有帮助。是的，绝对。我没理解错吧，你是受一位合格的资深PWP督导，还是可能受一位临床心理学家或其他HCPC心理学家督导？跟我们谈谈督导吧。是的，我想大多数人，至少在我的
experience, would be supervised by a qualified senior PWP who has undergone specific supervision training or approved supervision training. Maybe there are some people out there in services where they're supervised by other practitioners, maybebt therapist perhaps but no for me it's always been a senior pwp who supervised me so yeah supervision so you'll have at least so minimum of one hour per week of case management caseload supervision where you'll be sort of going through you know reviewing you know the patients you're working with you know any questions is you know, it can be like a reflective space as well, where you can reflect on, you know, what's working well and maybe some challenges you might be experiencing with maybe personal challenges or, you know, challenges with patients you're working
经历中，会由一位接受过特定督导培训或认可督导培训的合格资深PWP督导。也许有些服务机构里，他们由其他从业者督导，比如CBT治疗师。但对我来说，一直都是资深PWP督导我。关于督导，你每周至少有一小时的个案管理督导，你会回顾你正在合作的患者，提出任何问题。这也可以是一个反思空间，你可以反思什么工作做得好，以及你可能遇到的挑战，无论是个人挑战还是与患者相关的挑战。
with. And then there's also, I believe it's a minimum of one hour per fortnight of clinical skills supervision, where this is more in a group setting. So you'd be talking with your team, your fellow PWPs, senior PWPs as well. Maybe it's, again, a reflective space where you can reflect on particular cases and work as a group to help you all to develop your practice and your skills. And so, yeah's in the training year I believe there was more of that clinical skills or was on a different sort of schedule just because it's nicer to when you're training to you know have that more time to develop those
然后，我相信每两周至少有一小时的临床技能督导，这更多是在小组环境中。你会与你的团队、其他PWP同事以及资深PWP交流。这同样是一个反思空间，你可以反思特定案例，并作为一个小组共同努力，帮助大家发展实践和技能。在培训年里，我相信临床技能督导更多，或者时间表不同，因为在受训时，有更多时间来发展这些
skills but you still get a lot of that once qualified as well so yeah supervision I think it's really yeah been massively important to me i think important to all of us regardless of maybe what stage we're at in our journey what role yeah i just think you know having that safe space you know to to yeah to share and your experiences in this in this job in this profession working in mental health because it can be yeah difficult because you know if you had lived experiences yourself or something a patient might have said you know has has stayed with you and it's been difficult it's really important to have you know a good relationship with your supervisor have that safe space to share how you are doing you know we don't want to we need to look after ourselves and you know that's why I'm so lucky because every supervisor I've ever had has, you know, we've always had a 10 minute slot or so just to reflect on my own personal well-being and self-care, you know, to, I guess, really reduce or prevent burnout, really, because it's like that oxygen mask analogy.
技能会更好。但即使合格后，你仍然会得到很多支持。所以，督导对我来说意义重大，我认为对我们所有人来说都很重要，无论我们处于旅程的哪个阶段或什么角色。我只是认为，拥有一个安全的空间来分享你在心理健康领域工作的经历，因为这确实很困难。如果你自己有生活经历，或者患者说的话让你难以释怀，拥有一个与督导良好的关系、拥有一个分享你状态的安全空间非常重要。我们不想，我们需要照顾好自己。这就是为什么我很幸运，因为我遇到的每一位督导，我们总会有10分钟左右的时间来反思我个人的幸福感和自我保健，以真正减少或预防倦怠。因为这就像氧气面罩的类比。
You know, we've got to look after ourselves before, you know, we're able to really truly look after other people. So, yeah, I think supervision is really important in the training year and also once qualified. Absolutely. Supervision rocks, doesn't it? And it's not something to be scared about. I know when I first having a supervisory relationship with when I was an aspiring psychologist, it felt almost like I was being grilled and told off. But that's really not what it's supposed to feel like or what it's supposed to be like. But we have to allow ourselves to grow into that now i know from my experiences of of working alongside pwps and senior pwps you guys work really hard you have high caseloads and a lot of face-to-face sessions per day could you kind of give us a obviously not talking about clients specifically
你知道，我们必须先照顾好自己，才能真正照顾好别人。所以，我认为督导在培训年和合格后都非常重要。绝对的，督导太棒了，不是吗？这不是什么可怕的事情。我知道当我还是一个有抱负的心理学家时，第一次进行督导关系，感觉就像被审问和责骂。但这根本不是它应该有的感觉或样子。但我们必须允许自己成长。现在，从我与PWP和资深PWP共事的经验来看，你们工作非常努力， caseload（个案量）很高，每天有很多面对面的会谈。你能给我们一个——当然不是谈论具体客户，
but how many you hold in your caseload and how many face-to-face hours or sessions you're doing across a day ben of course yeah it's definitely a lot you do work with a high caseload uh so they say low intensity high volume i believe yeah so i for me, I have around about five to six assessments, which is normally done over the phone. So they're hour long assessments. And then I think I'll have around about 14 one-to-one clients. And each of those sessions for me and my service, again, because I work with long-term positions, is slightly longer.
而是你的个案量有多少，每天进行多少面对面小时或会谈吗，Ben？当然，确实很多。你的个案量很高，所谓的“低强度、高容量”。对我来说，我有大约五到六个评估，通常是通过电话进行的。它们是一小时的评估。然后我想我会有大约14个一对一的客户。在我的服务机构，因为我处理长期病症，每次会谈时间稍长，
It's 45 minutes a session. So yeah, it's quite a lot. And some of those will be made up of people who are delivering guided self-help. Some will be online low-intensity CBT, so through something called Silver Cloud. And yeah, if you're working with group, maybe that would be slightly less one-to-one. But yeah, it can be quite a lot. So I think for most PTPss it's around about 20 or so hours of clinical contact or 20 just a little bit more than that maybe which yeah doesn't leave a lot of wiggle room for other meetings and maybe other training or CPD admin as well because
是45分钟一次。所以确实很多。其中一些是提供引导式自助的，一些是在线低强度CBT，通过名为Silver Cloud的平台。如果你在做小组工作，一对一可能会少一些。但确实可能很多。所以我认为对于大多数PWP来说，大约有20小时左右的临床接触时间，或者稍微多一点。这并没有留下太多空间给其他会议、培训或CPD（持续专业发展）行政工作，因为
obviously you've got to write up clinical notes and you know letters and you know referrals etc so yeah it can feel quite a lot at times. So I think that's why it's really important, at least for me, to block out those times, putting in my diary, times for breaks, times for admin, times to take a break from the screen at home and put things down. So yeah, it is quite a high caseload.
显然你必须写临床记录、信件、转诊等。所以有时确实会感觉很多。这就是为什么我认为，至少对我来说，在日记中预留出时间非常重要，包括休息时间、行政时间，以及在家时从屏幕前休息一下的时间。所以，个案量确实很高。
But I don't want to put people off. It can be done just with the right support and being kind to yourself as well, of course absolutely job planning is so important i would not survive even in qualified practice without a job plan it really important and it's you know i too stopped for lunch just on socials yesterday i'd put that i always no matter how busy i get i'm always stopping for lunch and i've got my eye on the clock now because i've got a 1 p.m meeting and it's currently 11 58 so we need to make sure that we both both got time for our lunch, actually, you know, it really matters. And doing something that is non-work related, I find really, really
但我不想吓跑大家。只要有正确的支持，并且对自己好一点，这是可以做到的。绝对的，工作规划非常重要。如果没有工作计划，即使在合格实践中我也无法生存。这真的很重要。昨天我在社交媒体上说，无论我多忙，我总是会停下来吃午饭。我现在盯着时钟，因为我下午1点有个会议，现在是11点58分，所以我们必须确保我们都有时间吃午饭。实际上，这真的很重要。做一些与工作无关的事情，我发现真的非常
helps me to decompress and helps me bring my best to the afternoon and then beyond, you know, when I have to parent and do everything I've got to do Friday is an awful day Friday is swimming day like this is the worst day of the week like we've got to we've got to make sure that we are resourced and that we are putting good stuff in rather than just expecting ourselves to run on empty all the time because you know like you said like it's a year to train but then you've got to really want to be a qualified PWP. And some people don't think about this as a springboard to another profession. Some people will do this until retirement.
有助于我减压，并帮助我以最佳状态迎接下午及以后的工作，比如当我必须照顾孩子和处理所有琐事时。周五是个糟糕的日子，周五是游泳日，这是每周最糟糕的一天。我们必须确保我们有资源，并且我们是在输入好的东西，而不是一直指望自己空转。因为就像你说的，培训是一年，但之后你必须真正想成为一名合格的PWP。有些人并不把这当作通往另一个职业的跳板。有些人会一直做到退休。
They will be a qualified PWP, so you've got to be able to make this work. Yeah, absolutely. It's important, like you said, to have things outside of your working hours that you look forward to and have that to, as you say, decompress. That's taking your children to swimming classes or not, I don't know. But, you know, for me, maybe not. Having, you know, my dog is a big part of my life. So, you know, doing things with him, you know, spend time with family, friends, you know, sports, being physically active as much as I can be. Yeah, no, it's so important. Also, another point you raise, yeah, some people will stay in this sort of profession you know sports being physically active as much as i can be yeah no it's so important i also another
他们会一直是一名合格的PWP，所以你必须能让这份工作行得通。是的，绝对。像你说的，在工作时间之外有期待的事情，并有减压的方式，这很重要。无论是带孩子去上游泳课还是其他什么。对我来说，我的狗是我生活中很重要的一部分。所以，和他一起做些事情，花时间和家人、朋友在一起，运动，尽可能保持身体活跃。是的，这太重要了。另外，你提到的另一点，有些人会留在这个行业，
point you raise uh yeah some people will stay in this sort of profession and there's lots of progression potential for progression within the pdp world as well so you can be a senior pdp as you said you know you can you know go into more leadership roles as well as a lead of the pdp in the service so yeah some people may stay in this and that's okay you know everyone everyone's different aren't they they've all got their different aspirations don't they but yeah it's important i think yeah to have that time outside of work as well and not just make your whole life about psychology and mental health it really is and even this evening after swimming and it's not me it's tomorrow tomorrow going to a sausage and cider
并且在PWP领域内也有很大的晋升潜力。你可以成为资深PWP，正如你所说，你可以进入更多的领导角色，比如服务机构的PWP主管。所以，有些人可能会留在这里，这没关系。每个人都不同，不是吗？他们都有不同的抱负。但我觉得在工作之外有时间，不要让你的整个生活都围绕着心理学和心理健康，这真的很重要。确实如此。即使是今天晚上游泳之后——不是我，是明天——明天要去参加一个家庭成员举办的香肠和苹果酒
evening at one of my family members house i don't tend to drink at the moment so i'm going to take some posh apple juice but it's just about trying to plan bits into your week that help help the groundhog day to feel a bit less groundhog day i think absolutely important your dog sounds like a great source of support as well. Non-judgmental. Always happy to see you. Can I ask you a little bit about the pay scales? So when you're training, what band are you? When you're qualified, what band are you? Do you go up when you're a senior? Do you go up if you do any teaching on any courses? Talk to us about a bit about money. Of course. So as a trainee P2P, you'll be paid a band four NHS salary.
晚会。我目前不喝酒，所以我打算带一些高档苹果汁。这只是关于尝试在你的周计划中安排一些片段，让“土拨鼠日”感觉不那么像“土拨鼠日”。绝对重要。你的狗听起来也是一个很好的支持来源。不评判，总是很高兴见到你。能问问薪资等级吗？当你受训时，你是几级？当你合格后，你是几级？当你成为资深人员时会升级吗？如果你在课程中进行教学，会升级吗？跟我们谈谈钱吧。当然。作为实习PWP，你拿的是NHS四级工资。
And then once you're qualified, you'll be able to band five. And a senior P2P will be a band six. And then if you're a lead P2P, I believe it's a band seven. So yeah, you get up the band as you progress. Amazing. What a brilliant answer as well like so you basically got a span from band four to band seven which is really similar really to assistant psychologists are often band four i never made it to a band five i don't know they do exist i think it's very
一旦合格，你就是五级。资深PWP是六级。如果你是PWP主管，我相信是七级。所以，随着你的进步，等级会上升。太棒了。多么精彩的回答。你基本上有一个从四级到七级的跨度，这和助理心理学家真的很像，他们通常是四级。我从未达到五级，我不知道，我想确实存在，
service dependent um whether you can get a band five one. But then I went on to training at band six. Then when you qualify, you become band seven. So you might struggle to get to 8A unless you went into kind of service stuff or kind of higher up in your trusts. But there's very, you know, if you wanted to just stay in the PWP arena, there is scope for progression, which sounds really promising. Yeah, absolutely. Just before we finish, Ben, was there anything that felt surprising about your training or working as a pwp
这非常依赖于服务机构，是否能获得五级职位。但我后来接受了六级培训。当你合格后，你成为七级。所以，除非你进入服务管理或信托机构的高层，否则你可能很难达到8A。但如果你想留在PWP领域，晋升空间很大，这听起来非常有希望。是的，绝对。在结束之前，Ben，在你的培训或作为PWP工作期间，有什么让你感到惊讶的事情吗？
yeah so i mean what's surprising to me was you know the incredible amount of support that you do get through you know the training gear and also once qualified i don't think i'd ever worked in so supportive and you know mindful of you know your own mental health and you know personal needs as a practitioner really so yeah that was definitely one thing was that support and you know meeting other people from all different backgrounds with their own personal experiences as we said earlier bringing different you know skills uh different experiences to the table and kind of drawing from each other's was really really nice and just yeah it's so easy at least in my experience I was lucky that it's so easy to just get along with everybody and have that support and that you know there's a lot you
是的，让我惊讶的是，在培训年以及合格后，你确实得到了令人难以置信的支持。我想我从未在如此支持、如此关注从业者自身心理健康和个人需求的环境中工作过。所以，这绝对是一点，那种支持，以及遇到来自不同背景、有自己个人经历的人，正如我们之前所说，他们带来了不同的技能和经验，互相借鉴，这真的非常好。而且，至少在我的经历中，很容易与每个人相处并获得支持。在PWP角色中，
know within the PDP role there's there's a lot of skills that you develop and if you are interested in progressing further i think it is definitely a good choice i know obviously as we said about the health education england funding and the now new two-year rule and that may put people off but i do think it's a fantastic experience you know for future training um so that was definitely something as well and and yes you know it's you know the variety you get as well is really that's what appealed to me you know working with different client groups you know different ages different backgrounds different experiences different presentations so yeah i'd you know really recommend it for any aspiring psychologists out there maybe if they're graduating university or thinking about what to do.
你发展的技能很多，如果你有兴趣进一步发展，我认为这绝对是一个不错的选择。我知道，正如我们所说，关于英格兰健康教育的资助和现在新的两年规则，这可能会让一些人望而却步，但我确实认为这是一次非常棒的经历，为未来的培训打下基础。所以这绝对也是一点。而且，你获得的各种多样性也确实吸引了我，与不同的客户群体、不同的年龄、不同的背景、不同的经历、不同的表现形式合作。所以，我会向任何有抱负的心理学家强烈推荐它，也许如果他们刚从大学毕业或正在考虑做什么的话。
Yeah, I definitely think it's a good alternative if you're interested to, you know, stand assistant psychologist route. So, yeah. Absolutely. I think I would have found this really an interesting route if I hadn't done the assistant route and it had been available when it was my turn. One question I realise I haven't asked you is, is kind had been available when it was my turn. One question I realize I haven't asked you is, is kind of the prerequisites who can apply. So I'm guessing you need to have done an undergrad psychology degree, probably that confers you the GBC with BPS. Is there anything else? Do you need clinical experience? Could you go straight from graduating? Do you need to have known anything about CBT? Do you need to have
是的，如果你对助理心理学家这条路感兴趣，我认为这绝对是一个很好的替代选择。所以，是的，绝对是。如果我当时没有走助理心理学家的路，而且当时有这个机会的话，我觉得我会发现这是一条非常有趣的途径。我意识到我还没问过你一个问题，那就是申请的前提条件是什么。我猜你需要有一个心理学本科学位，可能还需要获得英国心理学会（BPS）的GBC认证。还有其他要求吗？需要临床经验吗？毕业后可以直接申请吗？需要了解CBT（认知行为疗法）吗？需要
clinically relevant experience? Could you talk a little bit to that? Yeah, good question. So I believe actually you don't necessarily need the psychology degree. You may just need a degree. And there are different routes. In my training, there was the sort of postgraduate route and there's also the undergraduate route so perhaps some people a bit you know older maybe has a lot of time out of education so maybe they want they prefer to do the undergraduate route but in terms of um you know prerequisites i think just having those common factor skills interpersonal skills really really important uh they do uh i think in my i was looking the day my person spec job description uh for my training role and it said that yeah essential criteria was some experience
具备临床相关经验吗？你能谈谈这一点吗？好的，好问题。其实我认为你不一定非得有心理学学位。你可能只需要一个学位就行。有不同的途径。在我的培训中，有研究生途径，也有本科生途径，所以有些人可能年纪稍大，离开学校有一段时间了，他们可能更倾向于选择本科生途径。但就前提条件而言，我认为拥有那些共同的技能，比如人际交往能力，真的非常非常重要。我记得我当时查看我的培训职位的个人说明书和职位描述时，上面写着基本标准是具备一些经验，
working with you know supporting people maybe with mental health difficulties or learning disabilities so for me yeah i um started after university so they've had masters and then i worked as a support worker for a year with older adults with learning disabilities and autism so that's what I you know reflected on my experiences also did some volunteering with MIND as well so yeah I used that in the interview to reflect on and you know demonstrate that I have had that type of experience before going on to the trainee PDP role so yeah I do think that's important so maybe people if they are you know fresh out of university looking things make you know some
比如在支持心理健康困难或学习障碍人士方面的工作经验。对我来说，我大学毕业后读了硕士，然后做了一年的支持工作者，服务对象是患有学习障碍和自闭症的老年人，这就是我反思的经验。我还参加了MIND组织的志愿者活动，所以在面试中我利用这些经历进行了反思，并证明了我在进入实习心理健康与福祉从业者（PWP）角色之前已经具备了这类经验。所以我认为这很重要，所以如果人们刚从大学毕业，正在寻找机会，可能
people may if they're lucky get on to a trainee PUP position but maybe they would like to do some support working experience or maybe as healthcare assistant or some other similar roles where they are supporting other people with you know mental health maybe physical needs as well so yeah yeah so important isn't it the engagement and the soft skills that you mentioned one of my favorite jobs that i've ever done was a home carer and i learned so much about dignity and respect and coronation street um Street from doing that because it's not just about the practical elements. It's about honouring that relationship. Whatever your role is in care or mental health
如果幸运的话，他们可以进入PWP实习岗位，但也许他们也想获得一些支持工作经验，或者担任医疗助理或其他类似的角色，在这些角色中他们可以支持那些有心理健康需求甚至身体需求的人。是的，确实如此，你提到的参与感和软技能非常重要。我做过的最喜欢的工作之一是家庭护理员，我从中学到了很多关于尊严、尊重和《加冕街》的知识，因为这不仅仅是关于实际操作，更是关于尊重那种关系。无论你在护理或心理健康领域担任什么角色，
is knowing that you can't just be expected to be accepted because you've got the badge or the name, you know, the job title. You've kind of got to earn that therapeutic relationship, that working relationship with your client. And I think for me, certainly my advancing age has helped with that as well. And my life experiences, you know, even having traveled independently around the world and now being a mother and, you know, having a husband and an extended family and having worked in non-relevant roles you know I worked in Argos head office for a while you know working on the
关键在于你要知道，不能仅仅因为你拥有那个徽章、头衔或职位，就理所当然地被接受。你必须赢得与客户之间的治疗关系和工作关系。对我来说，随着年龄的增长，这方面确实有所帮助。还有我的生活经历，比如我独自环游世界，现在成为了一名母亲，有了丈夫和大家庭，还做过非相关的工作，比如我在Argos总部工作过一段时间，负责
wedding list gift department and working in store support and doing temping roles in organizations across Milton Keynes like I learned so much that is useful to my roles now from from just my life really so I think that's a really good point yeah absolutely I think it's not necessarily this is what I've learned you know looking into applying for the uh Deakin is it's not necessarily you know what you've done is of course how you reflect on that and what you've learned from that and yeah doing whatever, even if it's not necessarily psychology, mental health related, those, you know, really important transferable skills like you mentioned. Yeah, you know, really can help inform your practice as a, you know, PDP, psychologist or whatever. So, yeah, that's really important, too.
婚礼礼品部门，做过门店支持，还在米尔顿凯恩斯的各个机构做过临时工。我从生活中真正学到了很多对现在的工作有用的东西，所以我认为这是一个很好的观点。是的，绝对是。我认为这不一定——这是我在申请Deakin时学到的——不一定是你做了什么，而是你如何反思这些经历，以及你从中获得了什么。即使这些经历不一定与心理学或心理健康直接相关，那些非常重要的可迁移技能，正如你提到的，真的可以帮助你作为一名PWP、心理学家或任何职业的实践。所以，是的，这也非常重要。
It really is. Thank you so much for your time. And so thanks so much for kind of pitching this episode to me as well, because it is so important. And, you know, we want people to be well informed about what this involves. You know, we want people to thrive in the roles that they're doing so that they can help others to thrive, you know, by doing their work. So thank you so much for your time, Ben., you know, by doing their work. So thank you so much for your time, Ben. Thank you for having me, Marianne. It's been a pleasure. You and I are going to get together again at some point to talk about the fact that you've got diabetes type 1 diagnosis
确实如此。非常感谢你抽出时间。也非常感谢你向我推荐这一集，因为它非常重要。我们希望人们能充分了解这其中涉及的内容。我们希望人们在自己的岗位上能够茁壮成长，这样他们就能通过自己的工作帮助他人茁壮成长。所以非常感谢你的时间，Ben。谢谢你邀请我，Marianne。这真是我的荣幸。你和我以后还会找机会聚在一起，谈谈你被诊断出患有1型糖尿病的事实，
and to think about that and striving for a career in mental health whilst managing those kind of physical health complexities. So if people have enjoyed our chat and would like some more of Ben, then do look out for that in the future as well too. Thank you so much. Thank you. What a wonderful chat with Ben that was. I feel like I've learned loads about the PWP role and the training and the career prospects too. How about you? Has this done what you needed it to do? Has it done everything that was advertised on the tin? Please do let me know. Please do drop me a comment. Please do like, please do share,
并思考如何在管理这些身体健康复杂问题的同时，在心理健康领域追求职业发展。所以，如果大家喜欢我们的谈话，并想了解更多关于Ben的内容，请在未来关注这一点。非常感谢。谢谢。与Ben的谈话真是太棒了。我觉得我学到了很多关于PWP角色、培训和职业前景的知识。你呢？这是否达到了你预期的效果？是否像宣传的那样面面俱到？请务必告诉我。请务必留下评论。请务必点赞，请务必分享，
subscribe, do all those brilliant things. You can also come along and discuss this episode with me on my socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And please do come and join the Aspiring Psychologist Community Group too. In this episode, Ben and I discussed imposter syndrome, and you might well find it helpful to have a listen to episode 155, which you can grab wherever you listen to your podcast or on YouTube, where I'm taking a deep dive, a solo deep dive this time, into imposter syndrome. You may also find it helpful to listen or watch the episodes on clinical associate psychologists. They are episodes 39 and episodes 124. You may also find episode 115, what is a mental health and wellbeing practitioner helpful if you are
订阅，做所有那些精彩的事情。你也可以在我的社交媒体上与我讨论这一集，我在所有平台上都是Dr. Marianne Trent。也请务必加入“有抱负的心理学家社区小组”。在这一集中，Ben和我讨论了冒名顶替综合症，你可能会觉得听听第155集很有帮助，你可以在任何收听播客的地方或YouTube上找到它，那次我进行了一次深入的、个人的探讨，专门针对冒名顶替综合症。你可能还会觉得听听或观看关于临床助理心理学家的剧集很有帮助，那是第39集和第124集。如果你正在
trying to work out what your options are for your career. Of course, there's a very special four-part series looking at assistant psychologists, which spans episode 148 to 151. On YouTube, there is a specialist playlist for assistant psychologist episodes too, where you can catch them all. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you enjoy being here and you are grateful, please do consider grabbing me a cup of herbal tea to say thank you. The costs to run this podcast are all met by me and I don't have any advertising or funding available. Please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and the brand new book, The Autistic Anthology, which is all about real life mental health professionals with autism diagnoses
努力弄清楚你的职业选择，你可能会觉得第115集“什么是心理健康与福祉从业者”很有帮助。当然，还有一个非常特别的四部分系列，专门探讨助理心理学家，涵盖了第148集到第151集。在YouTube上，还有一个专门的助理心理学家剧集播放列表，你可以在那里收看所有内容。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你喜欢这里并心存感激，请考虑给我买一杯花草茶以示感谢。这个播客的运营成本全部由我承担，我没有任何广告或资金支持。请务必查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书、《临床心理学家集体》一书以及全新的书籍《自闭症选集》，该书讲述了患有自闭症的现实生活中的心理健康专业人士，
and their experiences of getting diagnosed and providing a service to people in mental health. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month. We cover CBT, we cover research skills, we cover reflection, we cover personal growth and development, and most importantly, we cover believing in yourself and getting you the dream with this podcast that you'll see you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical
以及他们获得诊断并为心理健康领域的人们提供服务的经历。如果你准备好迈出下一步，请务必查看“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，每月仅需30英镑即可加入。我们涵盖CBT、研究技能、反思、个人成长与发展，最重要的是，我们涵盖如何相信自己并实现梦想。通过这个播客，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是由Dr. Marianne Trent主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Yana，是一名实习心理健康与福祉从业者。我读了《临床
psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体》这本书，我发现书中关于不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的路径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。